are you aware that there are immigrant
Advocates at State houses all over this
country that's right who are who are
advocating for noncitizen voting in
local elections check out this video
from Chicago uh a black uh Civic leader
who most likely will be called racist by
the end of today uh calling out the
nonsense of allowing all the uh illegals
into his City politically having over
500 people in our community would
completely wipe out any interest we
have are you aware that there are
immigrant Advocates at State houses all
over this country that's right who are
who are advocating for noncitizen voting
in local
elections what if that happened
here that would change the mindset of
what we as a black community need to
thrive here in
Chicago that's a concern of
ours this is much bigger than the mayor
of Chicago or Chicago Police Department
this is an effort to destroy our
neighborhoods and silence our voices
even
further while I do agree that it's
bigger than the mayor of Chicago it
should be noted that the mayor of
Chicago did want Chicago to be a
sanctuary City just like Lori Lightfoot
before him Ari it's good to see people
waking up like this guy's like uh well
this is a problem and we're not happy
with the Democrats that seems to be
pretty good right yeah uh just 8 years
ago you had people like Bernie Sanders
that actually had uh a good way of
thinking about immigration and they
realized the more people that they led
into this country the worse it is for
American workers the more opportunities
there are for these massive corporations
to find people that are just willing to
work for less and so throughout the 60s
7s you had classic leftism have the
position that uh migration on a scale
like this is just terrible and you used
to have like the the most hiled uh
activists on the left go down to the
Border when there were illegal migrants
trying to go through and they would
attack these people and actually Biden
has a bust of one of of these people on
his desk in the white house uh so he's
clearly turned away to the people uh and
how they thought even those leftists
back in the day and I think that a lot
of people actually will be changing
their minds as soon as they see the
complete shock here there was a chance
in America that all of this crazy
migration chaos would have just been
limited down to the border states but
when that all changed with Greg Abbot
Greg Abbot that uh decided to fly
everybody and bust them to the sanctuary
cities he made the problem affect
everybody the way that it should have
been uh and so he's changed the game
here and I think people are going to
realize really soon uh it's time for a
change mayor Adams is now constantly
fighting with the Biden Administration
uh so is pretty much every mayor in the
cities they're trying to get more money
so they can do something about this and
really just put a stop to it so yeah
people are waking up right now I think
they're going to continue to I do have
to give credit to my guy Ronda santis
who did ship them out to Martha's
Vineyard before Abbott was sending them
up to New York and Chicago Emily do you
think it's it is it cynical or just
truthful that in a weird way the
Democrats are basically like look we
have the black vote no matter what they
never break away from us so why give
them anything why not just ship a bunch
of illegals into the black communities
they're going to vote for us either way
and congratulations then we'll document
the undocumented and have even more
voters so as of two days ago they do not
have the young black vote at least
anymore which is a perfect reflection of
you are not safe in doing stupidity and
thinking you're still going to maintain
everyone's votes um I'm glad people are
waking up I'm especially the black
community and the Hispanic Community are
waking up because one thing Biden did
very well was overpromise and underd
deliver to these communities that you
know are marginalized or experience a
form of Oppression at least in their own
mind in the United States and they're
waking up like Biden promised us a lot
of things and he has given us nothing so
what incentive do they have to vote for
him again if he's not doing anything and
that's probably why he's letting all of
these migrants in because like AOC
stupidly said they are probably going to
grant them citizenship or at least
voting rights and these people of course
are going to want to repay the people
who let them into our country and vote
for them because he sure as hell has not
done anything for the black community
not done anything for genen Z not done
anything for the Hispanic Community
hasn't done anything great for America
truth be told and nobody has any
incentive but to vote for him so this is
now the Democrats Plan B what do we do
we can't lose this election boom let's
let the migrants in they'll vote for us
let's finish up talking about go ahead
Ari yeah there's one really important
note to make there and that like if
anyone should be concerned in America
about the migrants the black community
should really be concerned because that
the more migrants that come in here the
less the black vote matters I mean
that's just a matter of uh demographics
in America and how electoral politics
are played so as soon as you have more
of these uh immigrants that are going to
be voting uh a lot of these politicians
that have made the backbones of their
campaigns reaching out to the black
community they won't need to do that
anymore and that's going to be a really
bad thing for the black community so
they're definitely uh worried and if
they're not they should be right and if
if we're to believe that the black
community needs Social Services more
than rich white people well it's the
it's their community that will be hit
hardest when those social services are
moved to other
people